I feel like I'm still not good enough
for your trust
Fabby
[Music]
we need the last resort emergency
Edition these two are in need of
immediate assistance from a professional
Mary has a full-on panic attack when
Brandon confronts her about her extreme
jealousy after she repeatedly told him
not to look at girls at church
don't look at girls okay like I told you
to be physically controlled like where I
can work who I can speak to I don't
think anyone should have to live like
that damn right
let's talk about it
hey 90 days
it's melissia all right Brandon and Mary
by the way this is a nice shot of them
look at 90 day getting creative
oh it's so hot outside yeah
I'm sorry it's not here it's okay
Brandon has those long sleeves on too
the episode starts with Mary taking
Brandon to church I go every Sunday and
I would love Brandon to be a Catholic
like me
yeah more and more Mary is revealing how
big she is on her faith
I won't force him but he knows he really
needs to go to the church if he wants to
marry me remember she also says she's
saving herself for marriage
before having sex I want to wait for
marriage
and when it comes to Brandon
I believe in a higher power but when I
turned seven years old I kind of stopped
going to church because my mom stopped
forcing me to go to church so this is
definitely a new experience for me
inside the sanctuary Mary gives Brandon
this one rule
don't look at Grace
and to be honest the first thing that
came to my mind is you about to do this
in church
but then I said let me stop let me get
off my high horse let me not play like
our demons won't try to follow us
wherever we go
just look like at the priest
okay to
[Music]
live in that much fear in your
relationship
sucks
I'm drained for them
as you can see Brandon is trying to help
her feel safe
but it seems like nothing he attempts to
do will ever be enough
I'm trying to play it cool and be calm
but at the same time I'm just like
really like it's already a lot of
pressure to just expect someone to
basically adopt a religion so Mary
telling me that she doesn't want me
looking at other girls this is a bit
much yeah
he ends up telling him a CE times
a service
[Music]
thank you
though look at girls okay like I told
you
it was this moment right here where
Brandon turned his head slightly and
Mary's eyes went right along with his
tracing his eye line another trick girl
all about Brandon might not have been
looking at another woman there's a hard
truth that I've had to accept as I've
matured and that is
guys are going to look
I look I know it can still hurt but as
humans our eyes are attracted to nice
looking things
that's just reality but how your partner
looks and the length they look matters
you should always respect who you're
with
and of course the goal is to be with
someone who isn't so shallow that
they'll leave you just because someone
else is attractive if they would do that
then
they're not worth keeping anyway
the goal is also to be secure in who you
are and know that what you bring to the
table is good it's special and it's
Unique and it can't be found in someone
else I'm just like not understanding
what's going on and I'm trying to
fill in the boredness but if I even turn
my head she doesn't like it
and let's
that's
it just look at me when you're not
looking at this
you better run I mean danger danger if
she doesn't nip that in the bud now and
work on that
oh Brandon will be living in a cage for
as long as he decides to be with her
and she's going to be living in a cage
too
as a matter of fact any relationship she
chooses to be in with that behavior
will be restrictive and suffocating
look at Brandon he starts looking at the
ceiling
he is lucky to have someone who cares
enough to try to understand her and be
gentle
to be physically controlled like where I
can look who I can speak to I don't
think anyone should have to live like
that
[Music]
I just feel like I can't win
don't look at girls I know oh she is
trying so hard to protect her heart but
she has all the wrong tactics she's
worried about him being distracted by
another girl when she's allowed her
insecurities and jealousy to distract
them from why they're even there
didn't they go to church so Brandon
could learn more about her religion
meanwhile she's busy putting the fear of
her in him
I'm sure he couldn't think about
anything else other than what not to
look at it can't be like this forever
behave
later on Brandon confronts Mary about
her extreme jealousy
I want you to go to church every Sunday
I want you to know and believe that God
really exists
I mean okay I just want to be clear
about something
I am willing to learn but I don't want
to be like forced into submission
or told you have to sit here and like
not look or talk to girls
like like not even allowed to do that
you can do it if you want it's not about
if I want I can't like go out in public
or look at someone without you accusing
me of being a cheater
yeah my bad but let me butt in here
do you ever have moments where you
remember a cameraman or two and some
producers are sitting right in front of
them now as they have this conversation
it's so intimate I know as viewers it's
easy to judge them in their issues but
The Bravery I'm just telling you not to
look because it's Church why do you want
to it's not about what I want Mary
it's about you trusting me not having
this lack of faith in each other
Brandon hit
it hurry
which some
translates into a lack of faith and the
higher power she says she believes in to
take care of her
I just can't stop myself from being
jealous
I'm afraid to be left behind
I spent
almost two and a half years talking to
you on the phone never leaving you for
anyone else and then finally coming here
in person
you still feel that I'm the kind guy
that would leave you
[Music]
can't control others actions the best
thing you can do is work on finding
security within yourself
it's time for that Mary trusting that no
matter what comes your way or who leaves
you will be okay it will actually pave a
path for something or someone better to
emerge or for you to become better
my parents leave me and my brother when
we are kids
they didn't message us they didn't gives
us support
I think it's my fault and I think to
myself
They Don't Love You
every time I meet people I'm afraid that
if I love them
they will just leave me behind
I don't like it but I can't stop it well
it might help if she stops saying she
can't stop it yes powerful words even if
I got baptized even if I married you
even if we had kids would you finally
let go of your fear of abandonment
I need to know
Maybe
that's a scary answer
it's kind of hard to hold on to it maybe
I need something to hold on to
do
foreign
I want you to trust that I can look and
talk to anyone without leaving you
and then find someone else uh
she has to want to get better and
believe she can because she can there
are better ways to operate in this life
plus she has a man who was super patient
with her
he seems pretty safe to me
I'll do anything you want but you only
have to do one thing for me
and that is to trust me
I'll get the respect of your family I
let you hang out with your friends
but you know what's important to me
being able to like go about
my life I can't be limited like this
you don't need to ask permission
I'm not asking for permission
I'm telling you that even in person I
feel like I'm still not good enough
for your trust it has nothing to do with
you Brandon
I wonder if Mary's biological parents
will ever see this footage and if so how
would they respond she is struggling
because of a belief she made up in her
mind
as a result of their actions
what do you want me to do please
[Music]
next week Brandon ends up breaking down
honestly I don't know if I can just be
content and happy with this on a daily
basis
hurts so much when I feel like I don't
have this Trust
and I'm trying
really hard to just
hold on sweetheart you might need to let
it go
if she's not willing to do the work on
herself it is time to go
oh my 90 day fans fam
all right make sure you stick with ET
because we are covering it all I will
see you next time
foreign